[Music]
hello it's seven o'clock i'm nick
croishy you're watching sky news tonight
and a special question and answer
program on the cost of living crisis
tonight's headlines the prime minister
points to employment as the key to
easing the squeeze on households we
don't want to see any
kid any family going hungry in this
country we will do whatever we can to
help
chancellor considers tax cuts to ease
rising costs and blames global crises
for slow economic growth in the uk i
know these are anxious times and
unfortunately because the challenges we
face are global in nature i can't just
make them all disappear
coming up we'll examine how
international price increases are
eroding living standards here in the uk
[Music]
hello very good evening to you well
tonight we hope to answer as many of
your questions as possible as the cost
of living crisis intensifies for many
people across the uk coming up in just a
moment i'll be joined by our panel of
experts so first so let me bring you a
summary of today's news
the number of fines issued over lockdown
breaking parties in downing street and
whitehall has passed a hundred the
metropolitan police confirmed to further
50 have been issued but the prime
minister is not among those to receive a
fixed penalty notice this time
finland's president and prime minister
have said they are in favor of applying
for nato membership without delay
neighboring sweden is expected to decide
on joining the military alliance in the
coming days responding to the
announcement the kremlin said the move
will definitely be a threat to russia
and it would be forced to take
retaliatory steps
the inquiry looking into how the uk
responded to covid19 it's broadening its
scope to consider the impact on children
as well as people's mental health it
also plans to identify the lessons that
can be learned so it can be used to help
prepare for future pandemics
the waiting time for routine hospital
treatment in england has reached a new
record high at the end of march 6.4
million people were waiting for a
procedure up 200 000 on the previous
month in april 300 000 people waited
more than a year after being referred
for treatment and that is hundred and
ninety times higher than pre-pandemic
levels in february twenty twenty while
the number of people waiting more than
twelve hours for a bed or treatment
after they have been seen in a e reached
another record high of twenty four
thousand one 138
and rebecca vardy has become emotional
again while giving evidence in her high
court libel battle against colleen
rooney the i'm a celebrity star is suing
her former friend after she accused her
of leaking false stories about her to
the press
now social housing campaigner cue joe
trenebowa has blamed the government for
the housing crisis saying that social
housing has never been seen as a
priority the fundamental thing is um
the lack of care like i mentioned before
it's not being seen as a priority and i
mean we look at um is that because
people in gov sorry to introduce that
because people in government
don't experience it
almost definitely and it's i mean
having to deal with housing is a big
issue and i mean it's not going to be
bringing in money really for them so i
understand why they don't see it as a
priority but it should because it
affects millions of people's lives
they can see the full interview with cue
joe tenebo on social housing on beth
ruby interviews that is tonight uh just
under a couple of hours away nine
o'clock she'll also be speaking to the
russian ambassador to the european union
vladimir chishoff and former member of
the u.s colombo mafia family michael
francaisi so do join beth rigby for
bethlehem interviews tonight at nine
the prime minister has refused to be
drawn on the measures his government
might take to help people struggling
with rising costs speaking in
stoke-on-trent today boris johnson said
tax cuts were already in place and
insisted people will be further
supported in the short term but all this
comes as official figures revealed that
growth in the uk economy has slowed with
the rising cost of living thought to be
the main reason behind it
we will continue to use all the
ingenuity
and
compassion that we showed during the the
kobe pandemic and what we're already
doing as you know is helping people with
the cost of
of energy
9.1 billion package to help people
right now
22 billion pounds altogether
helping local councils to support
families that are in particular hardship
but the crucial thing that we're doing
is making sure that we steer the economy
through the
uh the post-covered aftershocks
with uh continued uh high-wage high
school employment and that has been the
real
miracle of the uk economy prime minister
people in work are still also having to
go to for instance food banks your mp
lee anderson said that food banks have
grown in part because people are hooked
on ready meals not prepared to cook for
themselves what do you make of those
comments we've got to support people who
are finding it tough uh in any way that
we can and i've said some of the things
that we're doing but when it comes to
supporting uh people who
who need
food for instance and families who are
facing particular hardship uh we we've
given extra money to councils and we'll
continue uh to do that you know about
the holidays and uh an activities fund
that uh that we've been supporting 200
million pounds worth of
support for for people who uh who you
know whose kids are going without meals
we can't have that we we don't i we we
don't want to see any
kid any family going hungry in this
country we will do whatever we can to
help but is lee anderson
is lee anderson right to say that people
are using food banks because they can't
cook the best answer
for the problems of uh of kids going
hungry which is in my view totally
unacceptable of families uh not able to
get the uh the meals any we is to do all
the support that we're giving and and
and
as i've said we will use maximum
ingenuity and compassion throughout this
period as we as we come out as we come
through the the postcoded uh
aftershocks
okay so that was boris johnson speaking
a little earlier today in stoke-on-trent
time then to put your questions to our
experts panel laura suter is head of
personal finance at aj bell the
investment platform and nina scaro chief
executive at the center for economics
and business research good to see you
both we're also joined tonight by sumi
rabindra kumar head of policy and
research at the trussel trust which runs
across a network of food banks across
the country ladies very good to see you
tonight thank you for your time today i
suppose we start with the questions and
that's what we're here for isn't it um
first question comes from twitter the
prime minister says that jobs are the
answer to the cost of living crisis
what about those in low paid in secure
jobs i suppose a question for you
perhaps laura to start things off yeah
so part of the logic behind that is that
we have very low unemployment at the
moment and so that means
that there's a bit of a war for talent
out there and so wages should rise
accordingly um but as this person points
out that's not very good for people that
are on lower paid jobs or just don't
have the ability to move jobs i think
the government's other solution is
people upskilling but clearly that takes
time it takes time for people to learn a
new industry or a new job so that's not
an overnight solution for people
struggling with their energy bills now
and nina maybe i can just ask you that
this really has come out of nowhere and
people do seem to need help now not any
later don't they
they absolutely do and especially
keeping in mind that for some households
they already had a couple of challenging
years with covet and now they're
entering this new this new cost of
living crisis right on the the back of
that and in fact i i wouldn't be
surprised despite the the current
rhetoric from the government if we did
see some targeted support in not too
long because i think we're going to get
to a point where the government really
doesn't have a have a choice but to to
recognize it more than more assistance
is needed urgently well we'll come to
perhaps what some of those solutions
might be a tail end of this question
most people using food banks
already have
jobs a point for you there sumi
yeah certainly in the uk food bank need
is a really stark reflection that for
many work alone isn't going to be the
solution um we see some people in work
we also see quite a few people so up to
about a third who've had difficult um
work experiences and are now between
jobs because of the insecurity in the
labour market
and then finally just to point out that
actually the really over-represented
groups who come to food banks in our
network um are people who can't work or
face barriers to work
um
so that's for example disabled people 62
percent of people referred um a disabled
that's three times the rate in the
general population
and so you know we need to face the
reality that jobs are not going to be
the solution for everyone particularly
if you're talking about tackling food
bank need
and we shouldn't be cutting whole groups
of people adrift by ignoring that fact
all right um let's uh hear from jim my
one job isn't enough jim says with the
cost of living crisis do i get
a second job so a fair question isn't it
laura should he
yeah i think a lot of people will be
facing this i think if your income isn't
enough to meet the rising cost of living
and the bills that you've got going out
you have two options you either need to
increase your income or you need to
reduce the cost of your bills and you
can do a bit of both but if taking on a
second job is an option and it's
something that you have available to you
then that can be one way of balancing
the books obviously for lots of people
it may not be possible to take on those
additional hours or to take on a whole
extra job yes nina for some
might be an answer to some but it's
perhaps more difficult
in practice for many
yes i do imagine that that some are
already working full hours at a job that
despite working full hours isn't paying
them enough to
to face the the very stark and you know
very rapidly arriving costs of cost of
living rises and what i think is a
particular worry is that given what
we're hearing now i feel i fear that
things will get worse before they get
they get get better in terms of the the
energy prices which also trickle down
onto prices of other services and goods
i think things are going to get uh to
get significantly worse in the coming
months so people that are already facing
problems are probably in for for quite a
difficult period and sumi what are
people telling you when they come to to
food banks are they feeling they have to
get additional employment if they can
perhaps the most very difficult for a
lot of people though
of course as as we were just saying
there are lots of groups of people who
come to food banks and people who are
most at risk are people who can't take
on those additional hours often because
they're doing unpaid work like caring
for family members or because they have
a disability or mental health problems
and so that option is really restricted
restricted for quite a few people and
that's why we see people coming to food
banks because they don't have those
other options available to them and they
also don't have the security of a life a
sort of adequate lifeline from the
benefit system
okay let's move on roli says it's clear
to see that many households are facing
significant cost of living crises and
this is going to result in people losing
their houses and jobs why can't the
government see this
and act now perhaps uh you can address
this for us nina yes i would say as i
was saying a moment ago i actually do
would expect the government to come out
with some targeted targeted um reliefs
in not too long um we were expecting if
we think back to the to the spring
statement we were actually expecting
some more targeted relief to already be
announced at that point and that was
certainly before the situation got as
bad as it is now i wouldn't be surprised
at all if in the coming weeks we saw um
some sort of additional one-off
assistance offered to people perhaps um
receiving universal credit um or some
sort of an um assistance to people who
who normally receive the the warm homes
um discount um so i think some sort of
targeted assistance rather than
something very broad brush
like uh v8t cut would be most
appropriate at this point and laura is
that the way forward something targeted
we know we had the queen's speech just
the other day much was made that hardly
anything was announced then to tackle
the cost of living crisis much debate in
the commons afterwards that something
did need to be done it does seem the
government is moving in that direction
to do something but is that the correct
course of action and will it help now
which is what people are really asking
yeah so i think the government has
announced some targeted support
specifically energy bills um we've had
the kind of energy loan scheme that will
kick in later this year and council tax
rebate of 150 pound for a lot of
households and i think it's that kind of
support that we're probably going to see
more of i think later in the year we
have the autumn statement which is
another kind of mini budget um but also
in october we have the next energy price
cap change and that's when we're all
going to see our energy bills go up by
even more and i think at that point that
might be when the government is waiting
to make more announcements about
targeted support particularly for energy
bills but like you alluded to there for
lots of families by that point they're
already going to have had to have taken
on debt to pay their bills um and
they're already going to have faced a
lot of financial hardship if we don't
get any help before then well stay with
us because that leads us to our next
question keith says i'm a pensioner and
i cannot claim pension credit i already
shop for all the bargain buyers and i
know how to cook but still i cannot
afford my electricity what am i supposed
to do many people will indeed be asking
that tonight i think so and i think he
sums up one of the big issues that we've
seen so far which is that pensioners
have been left out in the cold a bit so
what we saw is the amount that the state
pension increased by was changed this
year and so it didn't rise by as much as
it could have done and the increase that
it's seen now looks tiny in comparison
to the inflation rates that we're seeing
at the moment and no specific support
has been targeted at pensioners and
particularly those that live just on the
state pension um so i think lots of
pensioners are feeling like they would
have expected more support in the spring
statement that we talked about earlier
um and we might see more of that help
one thing that i would say is that if
people are really struggling there's
lots of help out there that people might
not necessarily know that they're
eligible for so the government has
filtered down some funding to local
councils that people can go and apply
for um so this is kind of help that you
need to apply for rather than an
automatic rebate like we saw with the
council tax um or it's worth going to an
organization like citizens advice where
they'll be able to look at your income
your outgoings and see if there's any
additional benefits or support that you
might be eligible to because so many
benefits out there are under claimed and
people could be getting more money and
nina let me put this to you linked to to
pensions peter asked what about people
living on a state pension 350 pounds
doesn't even touch the size opportunity
that's perfect for two people tax cuts
don't help us and the extra council fund
cannot help
with income and it has to be said of
course that people are getting a council
tax rebate well not everybody but
many households
but to fund the electricity the hikes in
energy prices this is a loan and it does
have to be paid back
yes or at least that is what is
structured at at the moment again i if
the situation continues to to worsen
it's not i know it hasn't been announced
yet but i wouldn't be entirely shocked
if what is now being sort of you know
discussed as a loan ends up being
converted to to a grand down the the
line we've seen similar changes in the
in the past
um perhaps for example for some of the
the kovid kovit so we've seen that the
sort of assistance offered can be quite
quite fluid
okay well do stay with us thank you for
all your comments and thoughts for now
uh you are watching to remind you a
special question and answer program on
the cost of living crisis here on sky
news and next we'll be asking why are
people on disability benefits being
ignored seeing the couple
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
i'm based in belfast the city
transformed by peace but still
struggling with its past
[Music]
on sky news we discuss and debate the
issues that affect us in a new lineup of
midweek programmes at 9pm join me trevor
phillips for common ground where i bring
two people together who hold different
opinions on current topics seeing what
might unite them i'm sophie ridge join
me for the take where we'll be
discussing the biggest political stories
of the week getting the opinions from
politicians and also our viewers panel
and join me for beth rigby interviews as
i question decision makers from all
walks of life exploring their views on
what's going on with britain today join
us midweek at nine on sky news as we put
people at the heart of the stories
[Music]
hello welcome back to sky news tonight
this is a special question and answer
program on the cost of living crisis
joining us our guest laura suter head of
personal finance at the investment
platform aj bell nina scarole chief
executive at the center for economics
and business research and sumi rabindra
kumar had a policy in research at the
trussell trust which runs food banks
thanks for staying with us let us move
on with these questions anil asks a
question while price is increasing at
higher rates than inflation this is
going to make inflation worse rising
interest rates will mean people will
have even less money to buy essentials
and that will cause the cost of living
crisis uh to get worse nina let me put
that
to you
no end in sight to any of this it seems
right i think i think there are two
quite distinct parts to that question so
first on one on why are prices rising
higher than the rate of inflation so
the way the rate of inflation is
calculated is based on a on a survey
where people say how much of their
overall expenditure they spend on
particular goods and services and then
based on those answers you weigh up how
much of significance how much of a wage
to give to each product and service you
put in what is called the the consumer
basket of goods put in this basket so
it's really yeah so it's really a
weighted average there are questions of
is what we're putting in that you know
metaphorical basket correct are things
weighted correctly so it's
it's very much a weighted average so
it's entirely possible that depending on
your own consumption patterns you could
be facing price increases faster than
what the typical consumer is is facing
and i often feel this way myself i've
been saying for a while i feel like my
own inflation rate is probably close at
20 25
you know well twice over the the other
part of the question was relating to
interest rates um and it's entirely
correct to point out that it's quite
unusual to have a situation where the
economy is
slowing sharply yet interest rates are
rising and it's a very unusual and an
unenviable situation for the bank of
england to to be in it's partially
because they're trying to control
inflationary pressures some of which are
still lingering from sort of demand
driven inflation earlier in 2021 and is
now being compounded by the russia
ukraine situation and supply chain
issues um but yeah to i do see the need
to to raise interest rates to help on
the inflationary side and the way that
that helps is by higher interest rates
mean that there is less money available
which controls the amount of demand
there is and controls price levels but
it's entirely correct to point out that
it's quite counterintuitive to being
doing that when economy is already
slowing yeah we see the interest rates
are going up let me put that to sue me
the uh the fact
inflation people facing rising costs
that's something that people must be
telling you as they as they come to food
banks it seems everything the cost of
everything to many is going up
absolutely we've done polling and that
shows that people are really struggling
with the just the bare essentials
um like clothing toiletries food right
across the board and actually it's a
combination of those things so it's not
just struggling with one bill it's the
fact that it's multiple bills that are
piling up and people are having to
choose which essentials they go without
or sort of how much debt they're pulled
into because they can't afford these
spiraling costs and it's really
reflected in the level of need that
we're seeing in
our network of food banks at the moment
which has been accelerating exactly
since this cost of living crisis first
emerged in the autumn and we think that
it's a you know set to get worse um
given the direction of travel of um
inflation rates i'll come back to you in
a moment ask about cookery lessons for
now though ian says my power is supplied
by a nuclear power station a solar farm
and one of the biggest offshore wind
farms in europe why has the price of my
electricity uh gone up perhaps uh of you
nina what uh how can you answer that
well based on the energy strategy we've
heard about recently from the government
it seems like their thinking is similar
to to ian's in the sense that they're
thinking if we can reduce our foreign
energy dependence and boost the sources
of energy that ian has listed there
solar um solar wind nuclear we won't the
country won't be as susceptible to to
future shocks but as we've heard from
the strategy that is really not going to
do anything with this crisis you know
their time frame is sort of
20 2030 and and beyond and the reality
is at the moment the uk
like much of europe is still dependent
on energy imports and even if we are
getting less of our energy than some
european countries directly from russia
it doesn't mean it's isolated from these
global shocks because the the the
sort the markets that the uk does source
its imports from are raising their
prices in recognition of the lowered
overall available supply because of the
russia ukraine situation all right we'll
come back to that in a moment and calls
for a windfall tax i know that's
something we need to discuss a question
for sumi this from margot i had cookery
lessons at school now uh children don't
simple recipe leaflets would help do
food banks offer fresh food that
question of course in relation to the
conservative mp lee anderson didn't he
claim that people who use food banks
don't know how to cook or manage their
finances properly can't cook can't
budget effectively what he had to say
in answer to some of the question here
around sort of fresh food certainly some
food banks and do offer fresh food if
they can
um and they have local partnerships that
um allow them to do that
um but really the point here is you know
that reflects the fact that food banks
will always do whatever they can to step
up and help their community as much as
they can but really it shouldn't be left
to
frontline organizations like food banks
to ensure that people can put food on
the table
and and the stark reality is that people
simply don't have enough uh just don't
have enough income
to be able to um put food on table and
afford the essentials our research shows
that the average income of someone
referred to a food bank in our network
was about 57 pounds a week
that's simply not enough to stretch um
across all the essential bills that we
all need to
pay you know keep a roof over our heads
food on the table and so on and so what
this comes down to is food bank need is
really about lack of income it's not
about food it's not about cooking
and that's the stark reality that people
are facing
and that's exactly why
karking back to your question about sort
of inflation rates why we are focusing
so much on the fact that urgent action
needs to be taken and to strengthen our
social security system so people have
that
lifeline to be able to afford those
essentials
and in particular at the moment bring
benefit rates um in line with the
inflation that we're seeing at the
moment and because otherwise people are
left without options
and really what they're telling us is
there are no more cutbacks to make let's
talk about benefits a question from
pamela why are people on disability
benefits specifically being ignored no
uplift pamela says during the pandemic
the warm home payment is about to be
reduced by 300 000 people a question for
laura is that correct what uh pamela
said there um so it is and it isn't so
um the warm home discount scheme is
being restructured by the government and
it's been targeted at people on
means-tested benefits
it means that an extra three-quarters of
a million people will be eligible for it
and actually the amount is increasing so
previously it was 140 pounds towards
your energy bills now it's 150 pounds
however part of that change means that
lots of people on disability benefits
are no longer going to be eligible for
it so that's where that 300 000 figure
comes from um and so
it means that lots of those people are
going to be left without that money and
still paying high energy costs and it's
worth pointing out as well that disabled
people generally face higher energy
costs either through being in the home
more or having specialist medical
equipment that they need that needs
power
or for instance needing to wash their
clothes more there are lots of reasons
why they would have higher energy needs
but also benefits haven't increased by
the rate of inflation and so their
income isn't rising to match that very
interesting all right thank you again
for now do stay with us you're watching
a special question and answer program on
cost of living crisis next we'll be
asking if fuel companies are making
record profits why are we still paying
such high fuel costs back
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello welcome back to sky news tonight
i'm nick quireshi you're watching a
special question and answer programme on
the cost of living crisis well as
official figures revealed that growth in
the uk economy has slowed the chancellor
says he stands ready to do more to help
people cope with the rising cost of
living rishi sunak says he would like to
cut taxes in the future and hasn't ruled
out a windfall tax on energy companies
but for many small business owners the
situation is already desperate our
business correspondent helen ann smith
reports
it's not just those who run the economy
feeling the heat a ceramics business
needs a furnace and it needs to be
fueled
at royal stafford they produce 75 000
pieces of pottery a week and that uses a
lot of energy they're about to
renegotiate their contract and they're
concerned
every day at the moment we're looking at
the mark we've seen
offers of 600 increase
you can't make a pop without without
firing it
so we've got to consume the energy and
we've got to pass that cost onto
the customer what are your worries then
for the next few months it's energy
followed by energy
and that energy
but for many businesses it will simply
mean producing less it's one reason the
economy contracted in march a drop of
0.1 percent worse than expected
and the streets of stokes speak to
another key cause a crippling cost of
living where people just don't have the
money to spend in the economy the
chancellor aware but for now resisting
more immediate intervention
as i have over the last two years i've
always acted to do what i think is right
for the country and to support our
country and families and businesses but
i've said when we when we have a clearer
picture about what happens with energy
bills we stand ready and i stand ready
to support people a lot of people will
say standing ready is not enough people
are going hungry right now and lots of
these things take time to implement what
are you waiting for well that's why
we've already announced things in
advance of this energy price cap
increasing
but for many it's just not enough like
pensioners meeting for crafts and a chat
their incomes lag far behind inflation
just one group reigning in spending it's
been a while since i bought anything new
so
i'm making do with what i've got until
something special comes along what have
i got to do completely
have the electricity
shut off all together and go but go back
to candles
and the other key problem is supply
chains a shortage of parts means a
shortage of cars and higher prices even
for those selling second hand
the the new car market um
the the stock is still
slowly filtering through the used car
market prices have risen we're paying
more for the stock as well
which has a knock on effect
it all amounts to a gloomy picture
forecasts are this will all get much
worse a recession entirely possible
this contraction in the economy is of
real concern it's come much sooner than
expected and before the cost of living
crisis has even reached its peak there
are multiple causes but if people simply
can't afford to spend their money in the
economy it will continue to shrink
leading to potential pay cuts job losses
and much more pain
towns like stoke already exist in the
shadow of historical decline the current
crisis threatens more the pressure to
avoid it mounting helen and smith sky
news stoke on trent
so then let's answer some more of your
questions with our expert panel joining
us tonight laura suter head of personal
finance at aj bell the investment
platform nina scaro is chief executive
at the center for economics and business
research good to see you and sumi
rabindra kumar head of policy and
research at the trussell trust which of
course runs a network of food banks
across the country uh great to see you
all right let's uh crack on with our
questions then raj asks with the rising
cost of living and economy shrinking is
it time for the chancellor to take a
radical step before the uk ends up in
recession
nina one for you much speculation that
we are going to
enter a recession sometime
this year the chancellor says he's
looking at various measures in what we
just saw there he really does need to
take some concrete action doesn't he
the translator is in a rather unenviable
position because he is actually in a
place of uh you know coming off of a
couple of years of
quite loose fiscal policy so basically
being very generous with public spending
in light of the covet pandemic so just
as the time has come for him to
basically raise government's revenues
via via taxes and to consider where he
can cut government spending he is now
being called upon to to actually help
bolster the economy in terms of what
we're expecting to see from the
chancellor again i would expect to see
some targeted support for the poorest
households i certainly wouldn't hold my
breath for a expansive
package of government fiscal support
again because of where their thinking is
in terms of just having had
two years of quite a lot of spending and
the feeling that that needs to to come
under control uh laura
he put this furlough scheme in place
some would see
this is fairly rapid but here we are
with a cost of living crisis that's only
going to get worse in
the next few months people will ask why
can't you do anything right now
yeah and i think people have maybe
because of the pandemic they've got used
to the government acting relatively
quickly and that was the phrase
unprecedented time has been used a lot
but that was an unprecedented time and
as nina pointed to we've now rolled into
another slightly unprecedented time um i
think that the government is trying to
have a balancing act between not
spending too much government money at a
time when it's already racked up a lot
of debt through the pandemic but also
trying to help people out where it can
and so i agree that i think we'll see
more specific helpful things like energy
bills
or more council tax rebates kind of
expansions of those schemes that we've
already seen rather than any radical
massive announcement of government
spending at this point and siri just
briefly tell me two key things that you
would like the chancellor to do
now to help the cost of living crisis
well we know that people can't afford to
wait much longer they're already facing
these impossible decisions around um you
know
their living standards
and what we really want to see is that
targeted support for people on the very
lowest incomes who actually you know to
date in terms of the support packages
that have been announced
in response to the crisis
have really been piecemeal they haven't
been targeted on people on the lowest
incomes they don't reach people quickly
enough and they don't go far enough
and we have a system that is
specifically designed in four
circumstances like this that targets um
support quickly and efficiently to those
who need it most and that's the social
security system so what we want to see
is investment in that system um
particularly as an urgent step bringing
payments in line with the information
that we're seeing at the moment it's
quite interesting that both the
chancellor and the prime minister has
talked about the steps that they took
during the pandemic as examples of their
compassion and their speedy response and
yet the glaring gap in the current cost
of living crisis and support that has
been announced so far is precisely that
investment in social security that we
saw during the pandemic like the uplift
20 pound uplift a week to universal
credit that is missing um and that needs
to be rectified all right let's crack on
the chancellor mike asks uh took 5p off
fuel tax but how does that help people
who can't afford a car in fact his
transport costs go up we have to pay
more to use public transport therefore
making us worse off would it not have
been better to cut vat so everyone
gained not just the better off perhaps i
can put that to you laura yeah i mean i
entirely agree i think that the 5p cut
to um the fuel duty for one didn't go
anywhere near contract in the price
increases that we'd already seen but
also you've got to be at a certain
wealth level to be able to afford a car
and lots of people as mike was saying
can't afford a car and so they're using
public transport and we've seen massive
increases in train fares for example
so i think what people would rather see
rather than perhaps some headline
grabbing news around fuel getting
cheaper is actually much more targeted
support at low-income families who are
really struggling at the moment who
couldn't even think about buying a car
and putting petrol in it because that
would be so far beyond their budget at
the moment all right andy says
successive governments have kicked the
can of long-term secure affordable power
supply down the road for decades why
doesn't the government consider
nationalizing all utility companies
electricity gas and water is that
something you might be able to comment
on nina well we have seen other european
countries considering
options such as nationalization of
utility providers it hasn't been with uh
much uh you know seriousness discussed
recently in the in the uk
we certainly didn't get any indication
of that happening from the government's
energy strategy that was discussed
recently i would say that even though
the sort of green agenda and energy
security has been talked about for a
long time i do think the next few years
are going to see more of a serious focus
on the
on the topic partially because of the
russia ukraine situation because no
matter what happens with the war from
here on out even if the war ended
tomorrow nobody is going to want to be
dependent on russian exports for many
decades ahead so i think despite the
economic downturn there is going to be
continued pressure for the government to
and private companies to continue
investing in in domestic energy supplies
um so i would expect to see more of that
in terms of where the government is
thinking the solution lies all right
john says can you please address why the
record profits for fuel companies like
bp are not being filtered back to the
people if these companies are making
record profits why we're still paying
such high fuel costs laura
yeah so i think um the difficulty here
is the government doesn't want to commit
to what would be called a windfall tax
previous governments have done it and
this would be a one-off tax um that's
focused on energy companies and those
particular profits that they're making
at the moment um clearly the tide is
shifting though on that isn't it even
with the chancellor now saying he's
looking at a pragmatic approach
potentially yeah it does seem like um
the weight of public opinion is shifting
it's i think it's a tricky one i think
um there are winners and and losers in
it and it's a fairly blunt tool to be
honest um
in
applying this kind of one-off tax
what we've also got to bear in mind is
lots of pension funds own those
companies and benefit from the dividends
they pay out and those pensions are held
by all of us and so any money that's
taken off those companies and paid in
tax is less money they can pay out to
investors which also impacts individuals
in terms of their pension funds so it's
a tricky balancing act but um yeah there
is a lot of weight opinion pushing the
government towards it oh we'll see what
happens on the windfall tax thank you uh
for now you're watching a special
question and answer program on sky news
tonight on the cost of living crisis
next we will ask what happened to the
job retention incentives for small
businesses during the pandemic after the
break
[Music]
so jim jim travels quite frequently uh
on sort of geology and archaeology
interest trips with other hobbyists
and
travel to iraq with an organized tour
group around a variety of historical
sites and mosques and things as well as
sort of desert desert ruins and things
in iraq um and on visiting a site called
eredu um found some pieces of broken
stone and shards of broken pottery on
the ground kind of asked
whether it would be all right if he
takes a few home to stick on a bookshelf
at home as a souvenirs of the trip
he was told that that would be fine
because they have no historical or
economic value that was confirmed by
the sort of experienced tour group that
he was with and also by iraqi ministry
tourism official and a former police
officer who was with them as security
and then upon arriving at the airport
jim was arrested and charged with
attempting to smuggle historical
artifacts out of the country and that
was eight weeks ago he's still in
detention at the airport so we've
received no kind of ministerial
engagement of any kind um we've we've
never spoken directly with any anyone
with sort of political decision making
capability but the the the fcdo are very
keen to to sort of point out and we
acknowledge they are providing consular
support it's worth calling out what that
is that's that is uh weekly or you know
every other week visit to jim to make
sure that he's been fed and watered that
is providing us with the phone number of
an english-speaking lawyer in iraq
um and
that's about it so so you know i mean
under the assumption that the foreign
office looks after british assistance we
run afoul of
injustice abroad um you know we feel
like this could certainly be doing more
and just you know we are just urging the
minister to just meet with us to discuss
ways in which you know
they are helping or or all ways in which
they can help
we've not spoken to him verbally since
since before he was arrested so let's
say to just just coming up on eight
weeks now um but he gets online uh our
time about one am for for between five
and ten minutes there's a flurry of
messages and
he sort of picks up what we've been
sending him throughout the day and
replies a few times and then disappears
again but
as i said the consular staff on the
ground have been to visit him and they
assure us that he is being part of food
and water and sort of you know his basic
needs are being looked after but
you know it's eight weeks in a temporary
holding cell in an airport in baghdad
can't be uh can't be comfortable of
course
hello welcome back to sky news tonight
you're watching a special question and
answer program on the cost of living
crisis families and businesses are
straining under a weight of global price
increases largely caused by demand
outstripping supply post pandemic and in
recent months the effects of course of
the war in ukraine well sky's ivor
bennett has been examining how global
forces may be eroding living standards
right here in the uk
the uk economy is flatlining this chart
shows gdp going back 15 years and you
can see we fall off the covid cliff and
then rapidly climb back up but the last
two months show zero growth in february
and a contraction last month of 0.1
now the uk is not alone it's mid table
in the g7 of major economies measured by
real gdp that's adjusted for inflation
and you can see we're growing slower
than the likes of the us canada and
france but faster than germany japan and
italy but here's the problem inflation
has soared in the last year reaching
seven percent in march and it's forecast
by the bank of england to exceed 10
by the end of the year the main reason
is the energy crisis soaring gas and oil
prices
have already increased domestic bills by
more than 50 and pushed up costs across
the entire economy and consumer
confidence is fragile we're no longer
hiding from covid but spending is
falling as fuel and food bills eat up a
larger proportion of our budgets and
then there's the war in ukraine russia's
invasion is not fully reflected in these
figures but it will increase pressure on
the energy market and hit grain and
cooking oil supplies around the world as
a result come the autumn household
energy bills may have increased by more
than a thousand pounds in a year
increasing pressure on the government to
act
tax cuts are being considered a one
percent cut to income tax would cost
five billion pounds and be worth 175
pounds to every taxpayer
but cutting income tax helps the better
off most and would come just months
after national insurance was increased
to fund the nhs
increasing benefit payments would target
the most in need they have gone up three
point one percent raising that to eight
percent in line with the expected
inflation would cost nine billion pounds
for a year but it would go straight into
the pockets of those struggling the most
whatever he does the chancellor says
he's considering a windfall tax on oil
and gas company profits to pay for it
first proposed by labour they say it
would raise two billion pounds but that
only saves 60 pounds on every bill any
help will be welcome of course but will
it but it will come at a cost to the
public finances the worst of kovid may
be behind us but the cost of living
squeeze has only just begun
either bennett there well let's answer
some more of your questions with our
expert panel in the studio tonight laura
suter head of personal finance at the
investment platform aj bell also nina
scara chief executive at the center for
economics and business research and sumi
rabindra kumar head of policy and
research at the trussel trust which runs
a network of food banks across the
country thank you for bearing with us
let's move on with our questions in the
last
segments of our programme tonight uh a
question through instagram does the
government have a long-term plan rather
than just short-term solutions laura we
know this crisis is going to go on for
some time so one would think that the
government would have to look to the
long term here
you would hope so but at the moment it
feels like they are announcing and
releasing policy slightly more off the
hoof and reacting to the current crisis
so
when we saw energy bills rise in april
ahead of that we saw an announcement
specifically about energy bills we saw
changes to the national insurance
increase that still brought the increase
in but adjusted it and made the system
very complicated to understand but made
it cheaper for some people i think at
the moment what we're struggling to see
is
that coherent long-term policy of this
is the support the government will
provide over the next year and instead
it feels like they're reacting more to
the current crisis on their plate and
how to deal with that nina is it a fact
that the government may be waiting till
later in the year to see really how bad
the situation gets before deciding on
any long-term action
that is possible but the risk is that if
they wait too long the situation will
get even worse than it would have gotten
if they act sooner so i think there is
already enough evidence to suggest and
to show just how many households are
struggling the economists are unanimous
in saying that inflation will stay
elevated for for longer um you have also
economic forecasters including um
including the bank of england expecting
a recession so i think there is already
sufficient evidence to suggest that it's
time to act now rather than put people
through further hardship before before
something is done all right talking of
hardship darren says i have a choice
council tax or electricity and gas and
food it's not hard to choose the winner
um assuming people are across the board
having to make choices aren't they
that's right and i think um really what
this
example shows from darren is that it's
there's no there's no longer really
choices anymore these are just
impossible decisions about which
essentials they can cover it's not about
having a buffer where you can start
tightening your purse strings and and
decide what to you know where to
prioritize your your finances
what people are telling us when they
come to food banks is that there aren't
any further cutbacks to make they're
sort of out of options and also food
bank managers are telling us that they
also feel that they're out of options
too that people are doing all they can
you know that they're trying to ensure
that they're claiming everything that
they're eligible for
they're budgeting
um they're prioritizing you know
what
they're on their household spending um
but there's nothing there's nothing
really left to
do to manage the cost of living crisis
at the moment
and actually it we do we have seen that
in our network for a number of years now
for some people but what's really
concerning is that this is obviously
accelerating and gatherings step in and
show that they recognize their sort of
emergency that's really unfolding now
for many people in our communities all
right we'll come back to you very
shortly adam says on the 5th of november
2020 the government cancelled the job
retention bonus a 1 000 pound incentive
to employers to retain staff and
continue topping up their furlough what
happened to the retention incentive that
failed to materialize the many thousands
of pounds employers are owed have a
massively detrimental effect on
businesses is there any intention adam
asks to repay
the debts uh nina let's put that one to
you
i certainly don't think there is any
intention of bringing that back and i
think the the chancellor has been quite
definitive in the way he's talked about
that the justification being that that
was cancelled because the furlough
scheme was extended now you could it's
certainly valid to ask questions about
is it uh is it reasonable is it fair to
make an announcement have businesses
make business decisions on the back of
that announcement and then basically say
that
that the things aren't that things have
changed and that that assistance won't
be forthcoming i would say
uh
in aggregate that the furlough scheme in
the uk was very generous and lasted for
quite a long time so hopefully most
businesses would have benefited that
needed at that time would have benefited
from the ability to keep staff on
furlough for longer and were were able
to get some form of assistance if not
that specific thousand pounds per per
employee coming back from furlough okay
five a question we are a couple this is
through twitter earning a total of 35
000 pounds annually after tax we are
bringing up three children spending on
basics and still saving some for
holidays why can't other people start
acting
wisely a quick one for you laura that's
pretty unfair to many people that i
would many might suggest yes i think so
i think but it probably echoes the views
of some people out there who think well
i'm doing fine prices have gone up a
little bit but i can still afford it
everyone else should just budget and i
think it just matters depends massively
on your circumstances um how you came
into this cost of living crisis whether
the pandemic impacted your finances
dramatically or not and so i think while
that person is doing very well um other
people are really struggling and it's
not just a case of cutting back on
netflix or shopping at a cheaper shop
and final word to you timmy in a quick
sentence when you hear that why can't
other people start acting wisely what do
you think
i think for some people they are
fortunate enough to have a buffer to um
choose you know to change their spending
decisions for people on the very lowest
incomes people that need to use food
banks um they don't have that option
they don't have the luxury of that
option
and that's why we need government action
to ensure that people are protected from
the very worst of the crisis that's
unfolding at the moment all right uh
sumi rabindra kumar nina scaro and laura
suter thank you very much indeed for
joining us on our special q a program
today
you're watching sky news tonight coming
up in the next hour russia's ambassador
to the eu tell sky news the expansion of
nato to include finland would be a
threat to the stability of europe
[Music]
[Music]
you